Normal, we color it.
Hey, Anand, how are you?
Hey, how's it going?
Going good.
So good to see you, Shashank. Yeah, can't be better than this. All good.
How about you?
Sameer.
So, all ready for the extended weekend?
Yeah, kind of. Let's see, man. What's on the cards?
Good.
Hey, Rachin, how are you?
Hi, good, thanks, Ashish.
I was just talking to Anil about the extended weekend. I guess it's good when it comes on Monday rather than on Friday.
Ohh, yeah.
Mm.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we do not get the Monday field, so that's really amazing.
Yeah.
Yeah, and you know what, Shashank, it doesn't matter what plan you have, but what makes you happy is that on Monday morning you're going to wake up late.
Get it, get it, get it, get it.
That, that's your, that's your performance incentive.
Okay.
Yes, but this does not happen with us working in India because we always wake up late on Monday. Yeah, yeah, it's just a small thing like we work in night shifts, so...
Yeah.
Ohh yeah.
Mm.
And.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
But always when it comes as a holiday for us on Monday, it feels good as well. Like not coming Monday, but next Monday I would be only like 25th because that's a holiday for us. So I would be taking a holiday in that case because I'm working with the US as well as Canada.
Mm.
Ohh.
So, I always get stuck because either it's the Canadian engineers working or the sorry, U.S. engineers working, so my engineers are always working.
Yeah, OK.
No.
Okay, let's start with the presentation. I hope everything is going good on your end. Things are pretty settled now.
Yeah, still getting there, Shashank. It's been a hectic, crazy period for us, and you know, we're just taking on a new client in the next week as well, so yeah, lots happening at the moment. We're trying to just, you know, manage, manage that, but yeah, it's going better than what it was definitely, yeah.
Okay, thanks. Great to hear that things are moving in the right direction. Moving on to the deck, agenda says the same, no change. So for Nora, I can see she has been performing well. She's working on tier 1 tickets. Last month when we met, she had some board management issues.
I addressed them. She took it very positively because she said, like, I want to improve. I said, like, don't be overwhelmed. Just let me know if it's becoming overwhelming. But she said, no, I know this is a, this is a feedback for my improvement and I want to grow. So yeah, this will.
definitely help me. And these are the kind of attitude we want to see in the engineers. And these engineers, if they have this attitude that they want to grow, even if they're a little bit less technical, I'm very happy with them because if they have this mindset, obviously they will improve on their technical skills because they want to grow.
And the growth mindset definitely helps the engineers to grow.
And she's getting good support from Anil and Rishin, both of you. She is really appreciative of how Anil helps her. So that's really good. So now you tell Anil first I'll ask you and then I'll go to Rishin because you work very closely with Nora. How has she been doing post our last call?
Has she been improving? Do you see better performance from her?
You.
Yeah, definitely I would say yes, I see better performance. And then she started coming out of the box, right, where she could deliver in the other areas, like other technologies. So I see a great improvement on our overall, yep.
Yeah, any concerns or challenges which you see and not even a concern like if you see that even a scope of improvement.
Mhm.
that we need to address.
Mm.
I think, yeah, I would say the right word is, it's not a challenge, but yes, area of improvement, I would say. So I would say two major points. One, she needs to learn how to prioritize tasks, right, and plan her day.
Sure.
which is like bored and of course, calling back the clients. And say example, if the phish emails are there, a lot of phish alerts, we send it to her because she has been helping out on that front. So she needs to prioritize those. And then second, she needs to plan her breaks accordingly.
because we prefer that our break should be taken before 3 P.m. our time.
Okay.
So if we take breaks, and there's a logic behind, right? If we take breaks after 3, 3.30 PM, then the end of the task, end of the day task, you know, those are going to just get lingered on. We won't be able to action those items on time. So if any tickets, which...
were not touched whole day because of the pressure and whatever, or any new tickets got assigned by the team lead, then those won't be action in time because you going out for lunch during the last hours of your shift. So I think that's, it's, again, I want to emphasize on this, not a challenge.
Yeah.
It is just an area of improvement. Yeah. So, which I think we all do, right? You as a manager, you do it too, right? You plan your day.
Yeah, it's a scope of improvement, yeah, and...
Correct.
So the critical task, critical tickets, you plan it in first half, right? That's how you do it. And then second half, you keep it for your research, follow-up, callbacks, you know, those kind of stuff. So I think that's pretty much it, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, I ignore.
Unless, uh, Shashank, yeah, sorry, go ahead, Shashank, go ahead.
Yeah, I just want to answer one thing. Like I totally acknowledge the feedback like the prioritization is there. I just have one issue though in this. The reason I would not be able to help her in prioritizing because I'm not actually doing a board management. I cannot see her tickets for details are there.
Mm.
Hmm.
So I would need your help here, Anil, and I know Nora would be able to do it. If you can explain how to prioritize, like if you can take up examples like in her QA and just give her a 5 minute feedback, not more than that, I know she would be able to grasp it. And I will let her know like there is some missing aspect which she needs to improve.
Yeah.
And once you do that, I guess she would be on track.
Oh yeah, definitely. I've been guiding her time to time. I won't say that she's not improvising, she is. It's just that we want to, and you know, it is something, it's a skill that you don't want to teach anyone, right? It's the self, I would say the self decision making, right? You want to plan your day once you sign in, you want to prioritize.
Rick.
Yeah.
your day, critical tasks go at the top and then low tasks go at the end of the day. So those things we want to plan it, right? And like you said, I will go ahead and talk to her and then that's one of my KPIs, you know, to guide team wherever there's an area of improvement and then.
Yeah, so...
ensure that we continuously progressing right towards the success. So that's already on track.
Yeah.
Yes.
So, yeah.
No, I meant to say like when she starts a day, any given day, not today, but any like Tuesday would be the next working day. She has got around 10 or 15 tickets. And I know you just need to do it once you let give 5 minutes to her till that.
Yeah.
Mm.
These are the 10 tickets you have. So these are the tickets that need urgent priority because this is the reason and she'll get it. You won't have to repeat it. I know she is so quick in accepting the feedback and improvising. So I think because I'm not live in the environment, that is why.
Oh yes.
Yeah.
I can explain her theoretically, but everything that needs to be done practically, she'll have more better understanding, like how to do that. Like, I know, like if a password reset ticket is there and official is there, password ticket needs to be prioritized, but with the actual ticket she's getting, like in official alerts, she has got five different.
Yep.
Mm.
kind of fish alerts, which one she needs to prioritize. I won't be able to tell that because I'm not handling those tickets. That's the area where I need help from you, but overall I'll give the feedback to her, explain her, and I'll explain the context why it's required. So.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
Mm.
Hmm.
The.
I think we should be able, we should see a good progress by next week. Okay. And Rishin, coming back to you now, tell me any feedback from your end.
Yeah.
Right, thank you.
Yes, thanks, Shashank. I think just a couple things from my side, right? Just overall, for Nora, we know she is evolving into this full system and this role, so it's going to take a little bit more time to get up to speed, right, with certain things. But what we're expecting from her is she needs to keep that proactiveness.
Right, where if she needs help, she reaches out, you know, if she's stuck somewhere, she reaches us quickly enough, 'cause you know what I feel.
is happening at the moment is that she's not looking at all of her tasks, like you know what she has there. So if there's something urgent that's let's say she's only getting to two hours later, it means that she's only reaching out for help two hours later, right? Which means it's extended time for us to then help our customer because now when she looks at it, she has to then...
Correct, got it.
you know, reach out for help and that extends it further, right? So idea behind the prioritizing is that she knows which ones are urgent based on the classification of the tickets and obviously she's worked in our environment for a long time. But definitely Anil's been guiding that to say, you know what, look at our big ticket.
Mhm.
Kip.
clients, you know, she knows who they are, make sure that there's some, you know, at the moment, I would say sensitive clients that we have as well, you know, that she's aware of. So, you know, I want that proactiveness to continue in that if she cannot do something and she knows that her day is stretched for some reason,
Yeah.
She needs to reach out at that time and say, hey, these two I know are urgent. They are burning clients at the moment. Can you get someone to help or can you help me reprioritize? And it will jump in and do that, right? But we shouldn't be doing it for every ticket. This is the thing, Shashank, you understand? Because there's a resource in place that's capable of managing their work.
Sure.
right? And all we want is to that proactiveness to continue in that if we have an issue, always have visibility. If you've got 10 tickets in the queue, these are my key ones. If a new one comes in, that's priority one, then always have that in the back of your mind that you know what, these other two are still urgent for bigger clients. So let's reach out and either get help
or get guidance, you know, on how that should take place. Yeah. So I think that's a key thing. And then the secondary thing is just because of the types of tickets she's handling as well, right? It's just to make sure that in all cases, the client is kept up to date. Because there's some tickets that are lower priority. We know that the client has put in, let's say.
Sure, Vikram.
Kip.
two week in advance, they put it in to say, hey, there's a new user starting in two weeks time, can you please? At least the bare minimum we need to do consistently is to be able to tell the client, you know, acknowledge the client and say, hey, we have your ticket, this is it. And then, you know, even if it's two weeks away, at least.
like three or four days later to say, hey, this is our plan. We're working with it at the moment. So ad hoc basis, Shashank, there is some misses happening at the moment where that's not happening. And then client is reaching out to either our team or Neil or somebody to say, hey, can I get an update on this ticket? Because, you know, it's just there.
Correct.
and nobody's even acknowledged it, right? So, and that's a couple of days later. So that's a bare minimum. You understand that we want consistency on. It's just that make sure it's there. If you're having any issues, speak to Anil. If Anil's not there, reach out to me. We'll figure out a way, you know, to help. But those basic things in terms of being able to acknowledge a ticket at least.
Yeah.
and to then give feedback in a couple days later to say, hey, we still working with your ticket or our target is this to complete it because you know, it's not as high priority. At least a customer knows we're working with it and they have a rough end date for it, right? Because remember with like user creations and stuff.
Sure.
Mm.
they may have their own internal process for onboarding the user, right? So for them saying that, okay, in two weeks time they need the user, they're putting it early enough so that we can give it to them maybe within a week. And then whatever internal processes they have to do, they then know that, you know what.
they still have the time to do that, to validate, check, you know, and stuff. So it's just that, you know, and I understand why it may be impacting Nora at the moment is because she's transitioning to the full system and this role and she's handling much more urgent tasks now, you know, where users are calling in or Nell's pushing other types of things.
Correct.
tickets to and she has to now adapt to be able to do those urgent tickets, but to still know, you know what, I have these other key tasks, I need to keep my clients involved, updated, and those things should be part of a day-to-day sort of thing. You know, we don't want to get away from that. That's the thing, Shashank, that I'm getting at, right? So for her.
Yeah.
It's always knowing that, yes, you're under pressure, there's more things being added, fine. But you can seek help, seek guidance, definitely we help for that, and we'll support her. But in some cases, we just want the proactiveness to be consistent, you know, across all of the things that she's doing.
Okay, Rishin, I totally agree with you. I just want to, I have some few queries and I'll work along with her. So the proactiveness, she is for the first issue that you told that was proactiveness. So is she being less proactive or you mean?
Yeah.
Mm.
I, I think, I think we've seen, yeah.
to say like she needs to stay proactive.
I think there's a fine line there, Shashank. And the only reason I'm saying it's a fine line is because I always put myself in the resources position, right, when I'm thinking about this. And my thing is that she is getting, if we can say, you know, additional tasks now that are different, right?
Correct.
Mhm.
And she has to adapt to that. But while she's adapting to that, she's also continuing with some of the new user creations and onboarding and access tasks, right? So I think that's where the challenge for her is now, is that finding her sweet spot, if we can call it, right, of being able to balance both these.
Correct.
and to make sure one doesn't fall away because I'm doing the other stuff now. So that's why from my side, I don't see it as, I see it as a transition. She's transitioning. We have to allow her that time to transition, but we also have to guide her so that it's much easier for that transition so that she knows, hey, I still have to do these things, you know.
Rodge.
Correct.
you know, I can't miss this. So if she has a checklist, then she knows that these are the things I still have to do, non-negotiable, because they are part of service desk and support, right? You know? So I think it's just more from that point, Shashank, and I totally understand where she's coming from in terms of transitioning and stuff, 100%.
But I just wanted to bring this up, because I'm seeing more of it, and I, you know, want to sort of...
push it before it gets to the stage of becoming a habit, you know, and something that's acceptable, you know, because that's where I think Anil is going to battle in the future is at some point she's going to be up to speed with everything, right? And we don't want to be at that point telling her, but you still have to check your tickets. You still have to.
Totally agree, totally agree on this aspect.
keep the client updated, you know, on all the different types of things. Yes, it's lower priority, but you still have to have that communications or client doesn't feel like, hey, F2R has disappeared suddenly, where are they? And now they have to send a follow up to say what's the status of this, you know. So it's just more that type of thing and it's just more understanding, you know, so, you know.
Correct.
Rick.
Rishin, just to add on to it, would it be good from this perspective if Nora receives a ticket today? She makes sure that she sends an acknowledgement to the client that, okay, we have received your ticket, we are working on it.
Ohh.
Yeah.
and will share the credentials before the start date. Something like that, or maybe some other ticket or whatever the request is. She receives the ticket and she sends the acknowledgement the same day, even if the request is scheduled after one week or two weeks, something like that. Does this work?
For you?
No, it's something, you know, again, there is a thin line, right? The idea is not to acknowledge the tickets and do a kind of fake acknowledgement that, hey, I'm working on it. And then we revert probably after like 2 hours, 3 hours, our next day. That's again, you know, not a quality delivery of work.
Correct.
So what we expect that, you know, when ticket is assigned, right, it's on the assigned status, right? We know that the SLA, we try to pause it, but the SLA to deliver the resolution starts when that assigned status ticket is given to a tech. So the tech needs to plan.
her day or his day that, oh, you know, these are the top phishing alerts, which means phishing could trigger to the account compromise, the thing that we saw in case of Kunal, right? So he acknowledged all those tickets in time that, hey, I'm working on it. And then there were no updates in the tickets, right? That what action was taken.
Kip.
Correct.
Correct, yes.
So, client was saying that, yeah, yeah, I'm coming on to that, Shashank.
No, I just want to ask. Yeah, I just want to ask. Yeah, okay, sorry.
Sorry, I'm coming on to that. So when Kunal acknowledged that, you know, there was no update given to client that what was done, and it was done for like 6 tickets. And then by the time, you know, I moved that ticket to some other L2, it was already account compromised. So.
Correct.
could be account compromise. So coming back to your question, it's okay to acknowledge that's one of your deliverables, right? As a tech, you need to acknowledge the ticket and tell the client that, yeah, I'm working on it, and I'll get back to you. But the time to get back to you, to the customer, is something that we need to have those senses in.
place, right? When I want to plan it, when I want to reach out. So if there's a ticket for password reset, you know that that's going to be priority because the user is not able to log in. So that time phish alert can be delayed for about like 30 minutes, right? But in the case when
Correct.
Same client is getting 10 different phishing alerts. That means it's a problem. You've got to have that sense that, hey, I need someone to purge those emails so that it's not going to spread across the environment, right? And could lead to a bigger risk. So that is expected from our text.
When I'm saying, I'm not talking about Nitanshi here, but it is just to give you an idea how you want to plan your day, right? And then after the acknowledgement, we shouldn't delay that, hey, I'm going to work on this because I have acknowledged and ticket is in the in progress status. I can work on this, say after.
Correct.
two hours or three hours or probably next day. It's not a quality work and we don't want to follow that practice.
No, correct.
No, my question was specifically for delayed requests. So suppose we have received a request. Suppose, Anand, you have sent in a request and Nora gets a ticket and the request specifically says like, hi, I am traveling after two weeks, so please whitelist my
Yeah.
Hmm.
Mm.
address for this country so that when I'm logging, I am able to do that. Now and this request should be revoked after four weeks. So if I get that request today and I acknowledge it like we have received your request, we are working on it.
Yes.
Yeah.
Hmm.
and we will deliver it on time. That acknowledgement I'm talking about, because what I'm not talking about any fish alerts or any password resets, because they are P1, they do not need acknowledgement, they need the action straight away. I'm talking about the request which are supposed to.
Yeah.
be handled maybe in three days time, 5 days time, something like that. I'm talking about those requests if we send an acknowledgement when we receive it so that the client knows that, okay, F2 has received this request, they're already working on it. It's not a computer generated message, it's an engineer.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Mm.
who has responded to that. Because whenever we create a ticket, we do get an acknowledgement from F2 that this request has been submitted. But when Nora sends in that acknowledgement, okay, I am acknowledging this request, I am working on it. So the client knows that.
Yeah.
Mm.
Yes.
Vince.
Hmm.
Atul has received the request. I know it's not urgent and they will get back to us. That's where I was talking about, not the normal tickets, not the P1 tickets.
Yeah.
Yeah, good one. I acknowledge that. Yeah, you rightly said it. Those tickets, we, of course, we want to give that human touch to the client, right? That it's not a system generated ticket and then someone is actually taking the ownership of it. So which is a good practice, yes. I second on that thought. Yep.
Yeah, yeah, so I'll work, yes.
Yeah. Shashank, just to add on to that, right? It's that the follow-up, what's more important after that, right? Because I think that's where the gap is at the moment as well from time to time, which is you acknowledge it in some cases, but then you don't actually do it within that SLA period, right? We know for new users, for example, whether...
Mm.
it's in two weeks time or three weeks time, we have a three day SLA for that, right? Customers are aware of that. So we're not meeting that target, right? We need to have a reason in place. So either we tell the customer, hey, because this is 2 weeks out, you know, we will action this closer to time to, you know, prevent you from getting billed early, for example, and all of that, or something.
Correct.
Mm.
that shows the customer that we are doing it in their best interest, right? Or we have it scheduled for this date and you'll have it before then. You understand? Because then customer has clear picture. And then if they say, hey, no, I need this earlier, that's why I'm putting it in now because I want one week lead time, then at least it helps in order to then know, okay, I can't do this in two weeks time. I got to do this in
Project code.
Mm.
let's say one week's time, and make sure by that date it's pushed back to client with the credentials and stuff, right? Just as an example. So the idea is the engagement to the client, just so that if the client says, hey, I got my own deadline that I want you guys to achieve, they would let us know. And then it's very clear for her that, okay, I need to schedule it by this date.
Yeah.
So...
Correct.
You know, as a worst-case scenario, yeah.
Yeah, so...
Yeah, so Rishin, what if we do in this practice and just to get a clarity on it, what if Nora sends an acknowledgement? Okay, we have received this request. I have read this request. This is from 2 weeks now. We are putting this ticket on hold and we'll action it next week because this is not an urgent request.
Yeah.
Yes.
West.
Does that some some kind of message that that sends out to?
I think the only thing we need to be careful there, Shashank, is we still have the three-day SLA.
Mm.
You know that we have to achieve for our clients for new users, right? So, so that's where we come back and that's why we put it back into client Scott to say, hey, you know, can we do this? Can we schedule this for closer to time? Or is there something where there's an urgency for you to do it right now?
Okay.
Correct, while acknowledgement.
You need to have it. So if we have that, yeah, if we have that visibility, then it's better because they've seen the proactiveness from our side. And for like the less urgent ones, they normally respond back quite quickly to say, hey, we all happy if we have it ready by 15, you know, when user starts 20th, for example. But at least then it's like schedule.
Correct.
Sure.
Client is aware that, you know what, if anyone asks them internally, hey, when is this thing being created? Because obviously there's different departments hiring and stuff, then they can say, hey, after all is going to do this by the 15th. You know, user starts 20th, but we'll get everything by 15th, all good. So it's just that you understand, Shashank, it's just more that communication with the client.
And just, you know, rubber stamping, because we we cannot tell the client, you know what, this is a lower priority item, because they will come back to us and hit us with client satisfaction to say we don't value them, you know, because why are we pushing it to the to to the two weeks just because they sent us that? They know our SLA is 3 three days, you know, for new user creation, for example.
Very got your point.
Right? So it's just that, yeah.
Yeah.
So, at...
Yes, so at the time of acknowledgement, if Nora says like, or if she asks a question, like, could you please specify if this is urgent for you or we can schedule it for some time later?
Yeah.
Yeah, I think, yeah, I think it won't be so much of A question. It's more of, you know what, we will schedule this closer to the start date of the user. If you have, if you need it earlier than that, then we happy to schedule that for earlier. You know, something like that, because it shouldn't be like a question because they.
Does that?
Okay.
Hmm.
Connect.
Correct.
Mm.
She has been doing that, so she knows, knows about that.
It's F. Jobs job, yeah, yeah, yeah, correct, correct, yeah.
Yeah, and just to emphasize again, Shashank, she has been doing it a lot of things, right? And I know, I've seen where the new user gets on board maybe like after a week or so, and then she says that, you know, I'll work with you on this date.
Yeah.
and then we'll help you with the onboarding. She's doing it. So this whole conversation, I'm saying it hypothetically, you know, like watching the things 30,000 feet away, right? So I'm not saying that she's not doing it and we have no intention to convey that message that she's, you know,
Correct.
kind of putting gaps, right? So yeah, she's doing it. Yeah, yeah. So long story short, you know, if you talk about the crux, the crux is that she needs to plan her day, number one. Number 2, she needs to plan her breaks as well.
Got it, got it, got it. It's just that the proactive measures need to be continued. Got it.
Yeah.
Correct.
Okay, and then on top, she, since she's learning new technical stuff, when you know that when you learn something new, you be extra cautious, right? Because you want to be, you want to, you want to do, try to do things 10 out of 10, because you're learning stuff, right? You know that there could be a
could be a possible issue, which you probably not aware of. So she needs to have that kind of third eye open to sense those, you know, the issues, which could be a potential problem in the nearing future.
Sure. Got your point, got your feedback. I'll explain it clearly to her, what needs to be done. So I understand and thanks for this detailed discussion so that we are setting up Nora for success only. Nothing else apart from this.
Yeah.
That's it. You said it.
Mhm.
Yeah. So moving in next, no to-dos from previous meeting, performance analysis, her utilization is going good. 99%, so that's great. Ticket closures are on track and they are meeting the targets. CSAT, now she is getting 100% CSAT.
I.
Yeah.
Mm.
Yes.
There are some areas of improvement and honestly, there would be areas of improvement for every tech. If there are no areas of improvement, that means the engineer has stalled. So we do not want that.
Mm.
Yes, correct, correct. Yes, exactly.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
True, I agree.
Okay, this is her attendance. So there were two unplanned leaves in April 13th and 28th. She got sick and we notified you. That's it. And we'll continue ramping up Nora so that she is working well and she is
Hmm.
becoming a superstar.
Great, and...
Shashank, just sorry, just from my side, I just want to check, is not doing okay, but because I know what the transition to the new, you know, to like the full system analyst role, there's obviously additional stress that comes with it, right? So we noticed recently there's a little bit more sick leave.
Yeah.
or unplanned living. So it's not a criticism, but we just want to know from her well-being, is she okay? Is she giving you feedback to say she's under too much of pressure and that's why it could be impacting on her health? You know, just for our understanding, right? Because we're always concerned about our employees' health and well-being first before anything else.
Mm.
And.
No.
Correct.
So yeah, we just want to know is everything okay? Because when we chat to her, she's saying it's okay and stuff, she's doing well. But when we see this sort of trend, we like get concerned, you know, is it something we are doing that's now contributing to this? And if that is the case, then we want to learn as well, right? Everybody wants to learn and improve. So.
Yeah.
Mm.
If there is something, please let us know, Shashank. You know, we are open, open to that, yeah.
Sure. I'm connected with Anand on Teams chat and I am connected with Nora as well. I talked to her. I'll specifically ask her if she is facing some pressure in this aspect because last time when I talked to her, she was feeling good, she was feeling happy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Mm.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Mm.
And she said, like, I have a lot of tickets to handle and I cannot do this assessment or training. I said.
And.
Yeah.
Time is given by Rishin and Anand. You can specifically say like, I need this time off for doing this of my training. It's, they will always assign you tickets. You need to ask for them. And they won't get angry because they have only asked to do, but until unless you won't speak, they won't get to know.
Or else?
Yeah.
Correct, correct.
Mmh.
So I clearly said to her, explained her, and it was a good conversation, but still, I'll put a check on this and see if she is facing any issues or challenges. I'll talk to her.
No.
Mm.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, I think I think that's important because Shashank from our side, yes, definitely not, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yep.
I'll not talk to her today for sure because I need to let her enjoy her extended weekend, but I'll definitely talk next week about this feedback. I want her to let her enjoy because sometimes engineers get sensitive like, oh, the service call happened and it was the feedback.
Yeah, Javid button, yeah.
A 100%, 100%.
That, that, you know what? That's what I was about to tell you: that I look, I have no intention to doubt on your management skills, and you know you being manager, right? And I know ITBD how they recognize people, but you know, whenever you're gonna ask her, we don't wanna convey that.
Yeah.
You know, in such a way that she'll be, oh, why are they asking me, you know, if I'm taking a lot of sick leaves or what, you know, it's no intention and Rishan, he said it right, that we have no intention to create a pressure for anyone. But yes, we just, we are overall, we are, you know, at the end.
Correct.
and we are humans working, right? It's not AI or robots working for us, right? So we want to have that human touch anyway, where we concern about the people and we rely that these are our manpower who make us successful, right? So keep that thought process in mind whenever you talk to her and tell her that she's doing
Good.
Correct.
Yeah.
good. Little tweaks, everyone has it, including me, you, and Shashank, right? And when the feedback is constructive, we work on it, right? That's the whole approach.
All right.
Pre.
Correct.
Believe me, Anil, I'll tell you one thing about myself so that you can relate to this.
And.
Yeah.
Every single tech who is working with me right now, they have given me two feedbacks. I'm very helpful, I'm very supportive, and I do not micromanage. And whenever I pass on the feedback, I pass on very easily. So they do not feel the pressure that's coming because I know a lot of...
Mm.
Mhm.
Mm mhm.
Mm.
people or a lot of leaders get confused in this where if a feedback is coming from a client, they put down the pressure to the engine and they do not understand like this engineer might collapse with that feedback. So I have this understanding, I've seen these things happening.
Yeah.
But yes, so need not worry about this aspect, especially. I'll get that handled in a very easy way. And I'll explain, and I definitely use the word scope of improvement, not readback.
Mm.
Right.
Hmm.
Great. Thank you. Appreciate that, Shashank.
Yeah, yeah. Anything else, Kris?
Um...
Yeah, I think, Shashank, just something, you know, just for you overall, just, you know, I told you that we are sort of evolving now and we have a new gem that started, right? So there's a few things that she's reinforcing, basically, right, from her leadership perspective. And a lot of that comes down to F12 compliance in terms of
you know, our policies and procedures, et cetera, right? So not a criticism again for Nora, but just make sure that, you know what, if there's no before trainings are coming in, most of the time it's like 3, 4 minute trainings at most, right? That she finds the time to do this in her schedule.
Correct.
Mm.
I'm not expecting Anil to go and add a schedule for a four minute or three minute thing to do that refresher training. But the refresher training is important because that is like cybersecurity and we just getting tips on how to do it, right? So all I want is that when these things come in, right?
Who?
Mm.
Connect.
Oh yeah.
Yes.
that she proactively makes sure she does it as soon as she can. Right? Reminders come in.
So is it coming only for your region or is it for all the region?
And it's coming for the whole company. It's all the regions, right? And it normally comes as a no before training. So it's once a month, right? That it comes and it's like a three, 4 minute thing at most video that she has to watch to the end, right? I did remind her a couple of times on email and I nearly chatted to her because we were exceeding those dates by like 3, four months. And now
OK, and then...
Mm.
Get got it.
Kip.
what happens is we have a team risk score in terms of for phishing and for all of these things, right? So it became a thing where they pinged me and said, hey, you know what? Your team is a higher risk because one or two of your members haven't completed their basic trainings that are there for a few minutes, right? So I reached out to her and I copied Anil on it just.
Ohh.
Yes.
so that when he has his discussions there, he's just giving a gentle reminder as well. But not a criticism, just a thing that it's been reinforced now, you know, from a F job policy side, that we must not forget the policies and procedures for what we need to do because it's securing F job, it's securing.
Mm.
Correct.
internal, you know, securing the team as well in terms of our thing. So yeah, just that and when, you know, they send this phish alert test and stuff, super important that she goes and clicks not on the link, but to click that it's a phish, right? Because that's another thing that increases the risk, so.
Mm.
score. So if we're sending these tests through and they ignore it, it means at a higher risk of clicking on a link in a rush and stuff. So these are some of the internal things that you know we need to sort of tighten. Yes, yes. So all we want is we want her to be more consistent to that and to take it in that right.
Correct.
Yeah, even ITBD does so. Yeah.
serious matter that yes, I'm busy, everyone's busy, but if my group head can do it and they are telling me, hey, why can't your end users do it or your team do it? There's no excuse for that, right? Because it's two, three, 4 minutes. So yeah, so it's just a more reinforcement in general that you know what, we have to still make sure that these things are sort of.
Mm.
I got it, yeah, and...
So, that as a TNC.
And I guess she is, she was not doing the training because she was under the impact, like I am getting tickets assigned and everything, but she needs to again prioritize the training.
Yeah, I think so. And she didn't realize that, you know what, it's only a couple minutes, it's not. And that's why when I sent it to her, I said, hey, this is not a 45 minute training. The 45 minute training is once a year, Shashank, that we do, right? But the other ones on a month to month is just 3 minutes. It's one video, 3 minutes of the latest sort of.
Mm.
Yep.
trends of cybersecurity and what you need to be careful of. That's it. And all they have to do is just watch it till the end. It's just a video. There's no certification or anything, you know, like they have to answer questions or not. Just bear, you know. So it's a simple thing, but yeah, as we're saying, we're trying to now with the new leadership in place is reinforce.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Some of these policies that people have, you know, not like pushed or, you know, feel is super urgent, but yeah, yeah, but she's done hers, by the way. It's not to say she hasn't after we send those emails, she did do all of the backlog ones that she had, but yeah, but yeah, yeah, exactly. It should be like proactive because the security part is non-negotiable for FTR, right? We SOC.
Sure.
Mm.
Yeah, but again, a reminder should not be sent. It should be done automatically.
I know.
compliant, we ISO compliant. So anytime our risk score goes up internal, it means stakeholders are saying, hey, we are not putting enough into it to further secure ourselves before we secure our clients. You know, so I think that's the key thing is that we have to make sure F12 is also secure, you know, and that's why these things are important.
Correct.
These internal initiatives that are happening now.
Sure.
Yeah. Cool.
Point noted, I'll definitely let her know, but all the discussions I'll do next week only.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, don't worry about that. And it's all positive as well, Shashank. If there's anything that she's doubtful of, just ask her to reach out to Anil and myself. We'll be happy to have a quick 10, 15 minute session on her just to realign if she feels that, you know, she's worried about a certain aspect or even if she...
That's OK.
Yeah.
Sure.
does not agree with it and she feels she's strong in that. You know, we want that feedback because the whole idea of the feedback is so that we can learn together, right, and improve together. So if there's something that she objects to, please give us a feedback as well because we definitely would want to realign with her and explain our situation in more detail so we can then come to.
Mm.
the future learnings, right? Whether that's from my side or Neil's side or from her side.
Yeah.
No worries, no worries. I'll definitely talk to her next week and I'll share it is of improvement with her.
Mm.
Yeah.
No.
Thanks so much for your time. I think that's it, Shashank. It's always good connecting with you. We appreciate, you know, the efforts you guys are doing as well internal. So thank you so much for that. Yeah, yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
The Sameer.
Thanks.
And thank you so much for the honest and open feedback. This will really help Nora to grow and to commit better.
Okay.
Yeah.
Cool, you have a good, good long weekend ahead there, Shashank. Alright, cheers. Bye.
Thanks.
Alright.
Pre.
You too. Bye.
Enjoy your time, Shashank. Bye bye.
You too, bye.
Thank you. See you.
Right.